[Music]
welcome back to careful boys the show
where we're real careful with real
careful boys everybody's careful now so
i want to be very careful and ask a very
careful question okay
i think you might be the second or third
dominican person that i've ever met okay
what are some negative stereotypes
[Laughter]
so i can get to know you better
all right and come up with a [ __ ]
what are all the racist stereotypes that
i can just use for other people
just to make sure that you're telling
the truth i'm going to be googling some
some of these stories
[Applause]
top three negative ones and number one
that we're all loud which
some of us can use our inside voice i
would like to be would you say your
family
yeah no we definitely are we fit the
stereo attack no yeah absolutely yes
people always think we're fighting and
we're like laughing and we're like with
the folk like we're not fighting guys
you have a lot in common with chinese
people no actually cantonese
you guys are right here with me my
bestie's filipina and i'm like you guys
are
right there like loud as hell loud as
hell okay love the food we do love the
food we eat a lot have you ever been
banned from a library
no chinese people are always banned from
a library that is a [ __ ] 11 year old
question i love it we can't whisper can
you guys what can anybody whisper
no whisper
i do
i don't even think i can't it says here
you guys are good at baseball
but that's not a negative that's and
that's fact we do dominate basically i
don't like baseball so it is a negative
oh dodgers this is a steep scale what's
another one then
let me see your trip sweat
that we're all sammy solstein wanna be
light-skinned um
who's sammy salsa oh sammy
cardi b's dominican right yes half half
but she doesn't really talk about the
other side i guess as much what's the
other happening
um i believe trinity trinidadian oh
trinidad tobago and they're kind of loud
too they loud they like the music she
loud caribbean as well if i'm not
mistaken yeah i think so
but i don't know i'm like well what
happened sammy sosa did see what i'm
saying that's what i'm saying people
think we're all sammy and it's like no
we should stand right yeah oh yeah yeah
i think it was very i thought you knew
that he did the michael jackson and he
said that it was a skin condition but
bull [ __ ] [ __ ] because why the
contacts it was
period for baseball like the mark
mcguire very bomb sammy sosa era that's
crazy he's not wearing the contacts
there but that's the same person
wait what happened did he did he michael
jackson yes but he claimed that that it
was like this
the texture of his hair i just want to
ask again that's the same person yes
what's your old picture look like
dark curly hair okay that's it
here's the color
by the way
as a hat guy i'm offended by this hat i
am too
and i just think you got to rock the
right one let's talk about it let's talk
about it there is no right one
no i will i will i will gladly take the
moment you've got to go and bring out
the happiness bruno mars working fedora
is acceptable i like fedora we love
bruno minus the hat it's my diss the hat
but you know what he does it though
right
tony chan
he makes night cap and we just made a
fedora for [ __ ] tinker hatfield
collab tinker hatfield all right so just
in case just in case guys can't wear
fedoras hey show her a picture of you in
a fedora bro that's cool she ain't about
it
why'd you say we like you're part of
that company because i'm gonna roll her
up like a blunt smoker from the hair
because he's a part of the fedora clique
it didn't click it's it's if you got it
you got it if you don't you don't i like
it look at how much like [ __ ] this looks
like
i love fedora
that doesn't crawl
that's a fedora that's an adventure
literally a fedora it looks like [ __ ]
that's kind of like what joe's wearing
that's a horrible round
i'm gonna get one made like that [ __ ]
that's a fedora though
yo out of all the [ __ ] we talked about i
don't think that's the fedora and the
kids
and it's okay my dad wears a fedora if
that makes you feel better look at this
door
you are right there what's the second
negative stereotype
she said the second one that was there
salmon salsa yeah they're all sammy sosa
like everybody wants to be light skinned
yeah everyone wants to be white what's
the third one third
to be fair though on the light skin tip
that's not just dominican oh no no for
sure i think that's like a sadly it's an
ethnic thing we all you know we all get
across the board a lot of asians are
like that [ __ ] for sure no for sure i'm
i'm which one you do some crazy [ __ ]
yeah
but i was gonna say like in dominican
republic yes we do get some issues about
like colorism and stuff like that but
not like that like that semi-solid thing
that's on another level like that's not
common in dominican republic so it's sad
when like americans see that and think
that that's all of us and it's like whoa
what america's so good at like seeing
one thing you're like that's what we're
gonna associate is uh is sammy's also
the most prolific dominican like i would
say he's definitely americans well now
cardi cardinals oh yeah
and i think that some dominicans kind of
like when the whole jersey shore thing
came out and everybody was like those
little italians like some dominicans get
upset about that but
it's kind of
yeah there it is
are there any smart dominicans i'm sure
there are sure there are two there are
you know
i'm sure there are what's the third one
third one i
that we're all hairy but that one's not
a lie that one's not alive never met a
a not so hairy dominican
yet to meet one
do you consider yourself hairy yeah no i
know i am let me see your arms i know i
am do you shave your arms wearing a
turtleneck man
to hide the hair
that's what it is no yeah no i wax oh
this is this is like it's it's been a
minute oh but when i was younger it used
to be worse like i remember getting made
fun of like in school i'm a dolphin
my sister got me i i remember my sister
has some hairy forearms too but i just
oh you're pretty hairy well she said
it's not hairy so i got insecure it gets
that bad no she said my legs are okay
yeah yeah i mean even for like a guy
that's not that bad but i get weird
who are the most hairiest asians
japanese japanese i'm not that hairy not
you i'm you just said most hairy
japanese people are pretty [ __ ]
really true yeah they got well i don't
know what i'm saying
wrestling
hair on his shoulders like like yeah
shoulder a little shoulder hair but you
can't even see you can even see on my
face a lot of japanese people can like
do the whole facial hair thing oh yeah
right yeah i know i can't connect this
yeah they gotta shave from my hair down
i can only have a fu manchu that's the
only one
yeah some of the chinese people it looks
like we got like just one hair only you
know what i'm saying like chinese people
look like catfish yeah i look like a
captain very sad i like captain that's
what it is
i feel like when you know all the
negative stereotypes of each other you
go oh we have that too yeah it's
relatable eventually yeah what are some
good ones for us yeah um that we're all
great dancers
but that's not the case not everybody
really i might have one type it's a
stereotype yeah it is a stereotype don't
think you're a good dancer no i know
well you should just benefit from the
stereotype you don't have to dance to
just be like put on the spot and then
they're like come on
at the family parties and i'm like no do
others find you a good dancer or is this
agreed upon yes but it's usually people
of other nationalities all right so that
you don't respect your dad oh so like
relative
yes stereotype you don't feel it but
like relative to like
people quiet yeah i mean it could be
like that yeah
is that where they do this will they pop
their hip like that is that
is that is that right i did perform it
before but you know no big deal it's all
right that was karate
that's
actually
what's another uh positive one um i
think about like our cooking which i'd
agree like most dominican people that i
know are trying the medicines there's no
uniforms in the east coast
yeah out here we don't have a lot of
restaurants because like most hispanic
people don't know our food therefore
they don't go looking for it or eating
it yeah what's the medication
my favorite is like our chicken it's so
good i shouldn't give away the secret
for non-dominicans but i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna say it's okay we use some
type of like teriyaki sauce to like
marinate it and make it like brown and
like juicy and so [ __ ] dominican to
use teriyaki i know i know but it's okay
guys it's just it's just one it's a
melting pot is it like it's palm sugar
no cause it's it's juicy it's juicy jerk
chicken tends to be a little i think a
little more like yeah like a rub down
type of chicken yeah it's a dry rub
there you go thank you um but no yeah um
ours is like juicy like braised or
something no not even it's like it's
just juicy chicken it's in a pot juicy
teriyaki chicken more moisturizer it's
like boston market with teriyaki sauce
because boston market they do what is it
rotisserie
that's not the same teriyaki chicken
flame broilers
tell me your best [ __ ] it's going well
today's video is brought to you by
amazon music amazon music has more than
10 million free podcasts including this
one wow that's like i can't even listen
for like my whole entire lifetime and
there's still more content yep but
amazon music isn't just for like
podcasts like this they have tons of
playlists and music stations that you
can listen to for free and no matter
what you're listening to you can listen
to it hands-free with alexa that's so
cool get the app and enjoy free
listening anywhere on your favorite
devices like your telephone or your ir
pads
all kinds some of my favorite stuff i
like to listen to on amazon is the
playlist so you can play
happy upbeat breakfast music and i'll
listen to that when i'm chilling eating
pancakes with taika and geo or if you
want to just have a random dance party
i'll play play dance music 2021 and
they'll play the hottest beats of this
year that's so nice it's fun i like to
work out to a bit like alexa give me the
hawaiian music i work out today so if
you haven't tried amazon music make sure
you go check it out they have thousands
of music and over 10
million podcasts to listen to all you
have to do is go to amazon.com
otr pod to check it out give it a try
it's awesome there's all kinds of dope
content for your ears on there that's
amazon.com
o-t-r-p-o-d
i'm really understanding the culture
there's got to be a debate
like plantains like we are known for
plants plantains are bombs is that both
where it's mashed is that is that that's
us yes but puerto ricans also eat that
too so our food is very similar to
puerto ricans and cubans we just changed
like the names ever so slightly are
puerto ricans or arch nemesis yeah who's
who's the number one people like to say
that and we do like to like roast each
other just like i know in the asian
community you all have like certain ones
that y'all like oh that's what we do too
what do you call them what do you call
puerto ricans this one's trophy yeah
he's trying to instigate have all the
poor people he's not he's he's curious
about the culture
how about what do puerto ricans call
dominicans i mean they just it's just
that they just do like they just talk
[ __ ] yeah we just roast each other and
talk [ __ ] or like we talk [ __ ] about
like
within the three caribbeans like that
like puerto ricans cubans jamaicans will
make fun of like oh who talks faster or
or who says like the dumbest cuss words
or this this that and it's like well
every all three speak really fast and
you do speak hello that stuff it's
actually chill i have to tone it down
we'll turn it up people of the world i
think we all agree that um the olympics
is the most prestigious thing that um we
all you just said you hated it like
yesterday
how many uh gold medals did you guys win
at this past olympics i don't know or
should i ask how few
oh wow you're messing up i gotta help
you
did we not win
what did the record show well cause i
googled it
and the united states has won 39
that's it whereas the drc
won't or the dominican republic won 12.
that's not that bad though 12 for a
small country
bitcoin ratios that's pretty good
we're very athletic people that's pretty
good yeah really good wow come on u.s
has a population 300 mil and that's we
got we got 30 people you're saying we're
losing the ratios yeah yeah we're pretty
bad what's the population of but we're
still bitcoin the dominican republic
because 12 gold medals is a [ __ ] ton for
a small population i was actually
impressed
is it for like baseball boxing yeah dude
for sure probably baseball boxing that's
10.8 known they got 12
they [ __ ] us up in the ratio why it's
because they've played only baseball
they're really good oh really i say i'm
not china vietnam nothing like that i
mean that's our main sport
best known for that is your that is like
the
not even close the most popular sport
there yeah literally that's why it's
always funny like growing up in america
and kids always wanting or even dating
like trying to talk to guys about sports
and everything and then they're like oh
basketball games and football and i'm
like yeah i don't know that and then
they're like why not and i'm like well
when my dad's older
and so
that's all i grew up watching baseball
so how would i know about any other
sport let alone an american sport like
if teriyaki chicken is your main
all-american baseball is there juicy
though it's juicy i go to a baseball
game there
is the country's local fare like a hot
dog with mustard
no not even i think you would probably
get like what we call futura which is
like a lot of like fried foods so you
might get that like it's like
chicharrones
yeah yeah yeah
and they got like these fried weenies
that are [ __ ] fire so good fried
weenies that sounds funny and that like
i said
but
those are fried as well like is there a
bomb dominican uh out here uh yeah a
restaurant or a district or something no
and i can't tell you guys off camera but
not to be [ __ ] up i'm not gonna plug
them in like that so i'm just being nice
i mean i'm being honest i'm being honest
i'm not going to hype up the one spot
that we have because one
is i you know
subtraction
and then you got to go to the east coast
that's where all of them at i know
that's but east coast isn't that far i
can't drive there right now let's say
for instance like new york all like the
dominican spots are really good at that
like what i said fritura and then like
chinese food and then there's like some
chinese guy that can literally
yes like bravo italian because you're
using teriyaki
[Laughter]
that's like louisiana fried chicken you
got fried chicken and then you also got
vietnamese vietnamese and chinese
chinese they got chinese food and soul
food together
that's it you get peach cobbler and chow
mein dude what about i i know i see this
in the east coast a lot but they're like
hamburgers they're they're really thick
crust they're called like chinese or
something yeah
well it's not a burger it's like a
sandwich but yeah i love chimneys
chimneys are a thing i oh i just
recently made a vegan one oh so good i'm
gonna vegan i just wanna try no i don't
know i just wanted to be a little
healthier that way it means like a torta
or something kind of sorta it looks so
good
they make them either chicken or beef
i'm a chicken gal so i like the chicken
one and then we have like a secret sauce
like the mac teriyaki don't say
i don't know i feel like yeah we got a
secret sauce it's called ponzu
don't want to tell me
but the chimneys have you have one no if
i see it i like it i want to try it
they're so good you don't get that kind
of food out here you know right yeah
yeah i've never had dominick hey first
of all nick why are you talking about
her now
[Laughter]
bro why are you talking about fast
forward
i'm trying to simulate dude i love
countries that are like all melting pots
because it's literally like why like you
know how local food's all mixed right so
it's a hot pot it's like tell me your
authentic dish and it's like teriyaki
chicken
that's like why i should describe it
okay or even like for us to understand
peruvian food has hella soy sauce in it
oh whoa this looks good no so i googled
dominican hot sauce it's called it's
called wasabi
this looks bomb as [ __ ] so that's
actually like a fun fact about like
dominicans puerto ricans
none of us have like any spicy dishes in
our food i don't know why we just don't
no spicy no spicy it's just not a part
of like and mexicans love jalapenos all
day all right
we're back to we're back to like noah's
ark right we gotta only save a male and
a female of every species right who are
the dominicans gonna send who who are we
cindy sammy sosa and not hello
he's marty carter and carter party's in
and they're gonna want to save roman or
i'll say this romeo santos which is
the main dude
yeah yeah they're sending them to for
sure who's that guy romeo he's like the
leader of aventura what's aventura big
bachata group
even drake saying about him spanish
girls love me like i'm having thought
all right all right
oh yeah we gotta save that guy the
dimples in the hair that's why they're
sending him to noah's ark like a
dominican ricky martin there you go yeah
he does look like ricky yeah
dude what the [ __ ]
what
the caramel dude melted caramel it's
like and i'm hungry
we were talking about the food the sword
i want that [ __ ] on the side
after my meat yeah i want to [ __ ] eat
him like a dessert
that's a wild statement y'all oh my god
that's a kombu lay dude
i'm all about all the national parties
bart's culture corner where he
interviews people and learns about
culture what do you hate about your race
negative [ __ ] yeah that's like uh the
magic school bus but like negative yeah
it's the racist school bus magic
at the back of the school board starting
what do you hate about your race yeah
yeah
and just to be safe we'll have 17
editors
[Laughter]
from the race he's talking about every
single denomination damn you navigated
that extremely well yeah he threw some
curveballs at you we didn't even know
what the [ __ ] she's like what do you
hate about yourself
exactly
what do you think about yourself that is
reflected in your entire culture there
you go how can i turn her own race
against her yeah we're against another
race maybe maybe we all learned
something maybe we could get a couple of
races to come and fight in the comments
how about that
i do feel like i learned a lot from the
dominican you know representation here
so thank you bart thank you that's a
good question
but thank you bart you know you got to
take risks you know i just want the what
the fritos the the
joe roger racism okay and i get the good
questions
three-hour podcast about racism
he'll teach us [ __ ] he just interviews
people
what are the stereotypes of your race so
you don't learn anything you just learn
about the stereotypes
do we cover all of them is there
anything else you want to add that like
he didn't ask or um yeah i think he has
to or he failed to ask an important
question why most dominican men don't
wear socks oh is that a thing it's a
thing i've been waiting to find out
i know shoes but no socks no socks
you think it is because it's a it's a
fashion thing kind of like armenian men
with the little high water dress pants
and the little loafers but there's mini
socks now though i don't like them they
like the cheddar toes i don't know why
cheddar toast sounds gross as [ __ ] it's
gross but doesn't that make the feet
stink the [ __ ] i told you that's cheddar
that's the genitals
i'm sorry i'm super uh ignorant to this
um the native language is spanish
spanish okay got it
but not i mean out there um like kids do
get like a dialect though because you
know like obviously we got like mexican
spanish we got like castellano in spain
type stuff like in dominican is there
something particular i was gonna say not
really like our slang's gonna be
different
you
[Laughter]
are you trying to say ebonics
real quick real quick real quick who is
the president of the dome
the dominican republic oh god on that
one
you're just like us yeah
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]